The delay, but good afternoon. I am Council Member Edward Pollard and
I serve as Vice Chair of the City of Houston Budget and Fiscal Affairs Committee.
I called this meeting to order and would like to welcome Council Member
Abby Cayman, who is in person. All budget
workshops will be conducted in person. Only public
speakers have the option to comment in person or
virtually. Also would like to welcome staff from District B,
District F, District H, District I,
at large position three, and at large position 448
hours prior to the start of all workshop presentations,
materials are uploaded to SharePoint and hard copies delivered to each
council office. The budget workshop schedule has been posted
to the BFA website. Questions from council
members can be uploaded at any time during the budget workshop process,
the earlier the better, allowing the departments plenty of time to provide
responses. All departments have been directed to provide
written responses within 48 hours of the conclusion of
their presentation. To any question posted by council members
to SharePoint, all public speakers should be
signed in to speak. If you have not signed up,
please sign in now. At the front table, district E
Staff Member Carolina will be monitoring the public speakers list.
Council members, the fiscal year 2023
budget amendment template has also been uploaded to the SharePoint
Budget Workspace. Mayor Turner sent out a memo to
all council members and council offices to ensure productive discussions
on the fiscal year 2023 proposed budget reminder
only operational budget related amendments will be considered.
Policy amendments, as in years past, will be ruled out of
order. Please see the Mayor's memo for additional guidance.
Amendments are due on Wednesday, May 25.
We also have Council member Sally Alcorn in chambers.
In person? This afternoon we will hear from
Legal Department, Planning and Development Department,
administrative Office of City Council, administrative and
Regulatory Affairs Department, as well as the Municipal
courts. As a reminder, the only people attending virtually
are public speakers. We'll get to their questions after
the presentations and questions from council have concluded.
At this time, I would like to welcome City Attorney Arturo Michelle
and Thy Ruiz to provide the legal budget presentation.
The floor is yours.
Um, let's begin with
the second chart. This is the functional.org chart that
we have. This includes the different sections,
the overall and the dollars associated
with them. And this is from all three of the funds that
affect the legal department the General Fund, the Property and Casualty,
and the Workers Comp funds. It excludes any
positions funded by enterprise funds. They're part of other
department budgets, such as public works and airport.
The next slide and
the following one describe what we do some
of the major areas. Of course, everyone here at the table is intimately
familiar with it. I would like to point out that we do
deal perhaps more than other cities in certain areas,
such as planning and development issues.
We don't follow the zoning scheme, the regulatory scheme that many
cities do that presents particular challenges.
We often deal with regulatory or
statutory contract compliance. There are issues where the state challenges us
on preemption issue of water rights and so on. So we have
more activity than I think many cities do in that area.
Also, with our protection of neighborhoods,
again not being zoned deed restrictions,
that brings up particular issues that requires a lot of investigation,
assessment and analysis challenging those
entities or persons who we believe are violating the law.
And then we deal with a huge number of contracts and the
contract issues. And I would like to point out now,
although I could do it later, when I talk about some of the accomplishments,
that in contracts, in government contracting,
what is valued is transparency and
avoiding any fraud or other illegalities that
slows the process down. So we work constantly with strategic procurement
to try to do our best to improve the processes and get the
departments the contracts that they need.
The next page shows some of what
I'm talking about. And also our
labor lawyers, in addition to litigation,
have in fact their largest volume is probably the adverse matters,
the contested case matters that are not litigated before the Civil Service Commission,
issues before Department of labor or
EEOC, things of that nature.
In the following slide, it reflects
in part some of our priorities of the financial or societal impact
of service delivery. Our complete communities initiatives
of the city is one where we provide
support services. We try to do what we can to accelerate the
process, whether it's a transactional or whether it's an assessment and
analysis of what can be done. And then we anticipate
growth in areas that have been growing for
a number of years now. Public works with
our aging infrastructure system and our utility system,
the airport system always has new and
pretty significant issues. Housing is going
to continue to be an issue here in Houston and in most places
in Texas for quite a while. The police department with
the onesafe Houston is something that we have
spent a big focus on, not only an ordinance, but I would
like to point out the Office of
Policing Accountability has
been housed in our OIG department.
It really takes the lead, crystal Lakora for in many of these initiatives,
in explaining what's happening in the community, in taking complaints,
in putting out as much information as we can so the public understands
what the city of Houston is doing.
The next slide gets we start getting into the
numbers here. It's the following slide the
revenue by funds and this is
money that comes in. So I'll get to the expenditures next. But this
is the revenue by funds and as you can see that
there's an increase in both the general fund and property and casualty.
Property and casualty fund revenue is just increased to
reflect the increased expenditures. The general
fund increase is due primarily to vacancies. We've had
an issue in being able to staff our department.
I think that's generally true of many local
government, public sector legal departments.
But here it has become a big issue that
I think we've been able to solve by having market adjustments
to increase. I think the mayor worked with us and he
did, I thought, a remarkable job of being able to fund market increases.
So we are no longer at the bottom of the major cities in Texas
and then other major local government units
such as Metro, Harris County.
And the following slide reflects just what I was saying. Right now,
the revenue highlights. The General Fund shows
the vacancies of savings there and then the property and
casualty revenues to match the expenditures in the funds. Now,
the following slide gets into expenditure
by funds and we
go to the three major funds that I've discussed before.
As you can see, there's a bigger bump in
the Workers Comp Fund, but that's a smaller one. And so it's
probably better to explain that and these others in the following slides where we
can get into the details. But you can see here that the General Fund has
an increase of about 17% and about 6%
for the property and Casualty fund. So the following slide,
if you look at this, you'll see the two dark bars toward the
top. What's in under that first bar
is really the net change to FY 2022.
And then below the second bar is the FY 2023
expenditure. So what you can see here is
we have an operating budget to begin with. Then you
add in the Hope adjustment,
then you have additional staff and pay adjustments.
So that is part of what I was talking about before with the
increase. And then below that you have restricted accounts.
And restricted accounts are it Application Data services.
The law has increasingly become dependent on technology
in order to be able to do the job that you need to do to
provide quality legal work.
Going below the second bar, if you look at the
FY 2023, you can see there
a reflection of some of the remarks I've made to date.
The program adjustments are in the department market
salary increase, the additional staff and
pay adjustments, and then the parenthetical,
the 216. The negative just reflects a personnel transfer
from one fund to another. Then there are contractual
or mandated adjustments. That includes Hope,
again, restricted accounts and then health benefits make
up that last number, 44. And so
if you look at the difference between the two budgets, that yields
a 17% change.
This was set up to set questions for last. But if you
have questions at any point, please ask me. I don't want to overlook a slide
where it may be confusing to you. The following
slide slide ten. This is the highlights.
It's an important aspect of the increase is the market
salary increase to bring us up to competitive with the
other entities to which we were
losing attorneys, frankly, in addition to the
private sector. And then the funding that is required to
be made for health benefits, for hope and so on. And then the funding
for our outside counsel, litigation support, claims and
judgments.
The following slide number eleven is
this. Now I begin a series of charts to show
where the money is going within a fund. So this is the general fund.
If you look at the left, you'll see that
personnel makes up 92% of the costs. And that's very typical for
any legal department, law firm anywhere.
That's generally where you have a huge bulk of your cost.
Non personnel is 8%. The pie chart to
the right, where the arrow is pointing, breaks down the non personnel.
So you have the restricted accounts that make up about
half. And those restricted accounts are the It applications,
data Services, voice Services, insurance Fees,
GIS, HR, client Services, things of that
nature. Then you have other services that make up 18%.
And this is Annex. Parking software, maintenance,
mail services, code of ordinance printing,
CLE bar dues. Travel supplies
are office and computer supplies. That's another 12%.
General Office Services. Those are in the nature of
Westlaw title data. And then paying
the Harris County Department of Ed for archived services, and then
the legal services. The 9% is outside counsel
that we use for immigration visas, artificial intelligence,
things of that nature. And then supplies are your standard office
and computer supplies.
The next slide, twelve shows the property
and casualty fund. And there you see the numbers
are reversed because this
is from which we pay our claims. So personnel makes
up only 35%, whereas non personnel makes up 65%.
And then looking at the pie chart to the right, you can see that the
bulk of the expenditures there are
anticipated for claims, settlements, judgments, attorneys fees,
legal services are outside counsel fees,
litigation support. Those are expert witnesses,
court reporters, medical services, document reading,
things of that nature. Then we have supplies and
restricted accounts, and then other services which were the
professional and membership fees, west law, travel, things of that nature.
Then the next slide shows the workers comp.
And as you can see, personnel makes up the bulk of
that, about three, four, and then non personnel
is about a fourth. And if you look at to the
right, you'll see that the restricted accounts, again, the It
Application Data Services, et cetera, make up the bulk of
that supplies, a small amount. And then the other services,
the parking, the software, and so on.
So that's how the workers fund compensation fund breaks
down. So at this point,
I'm opening up to questions, and all I really have left after that is
just a glossary, our chart, and then some
demographic data and the department accomplishments.
Thank you, Arturo, for your presentation.
A couple of questions. Try to explain to
the public. The main differences between your
public law practice and a private law practice? Are there things within
your department that we are significantly lacking as
opposed to a private law firm? Whether it's with software or any other
applications,
certain law firms can afford the newest and the best technology
we have been able to manage. Obviously,
with more funds you can purchase more
also more of the technology so it's spread out among fewer
people when you do that. We have, for example,
body camera footage that has to be reviewed,
that has to be edited to pinpoint, to be able to present
in any litigation or any other matter. So you do have that constraint,
but we have been able to find
funds to get the software and the technology we need,
we think, to be able to do as good a job as can be
expected. Are there any outside of the general
fund opportunities for additional dollars or funds
that come into your department outside
of property casualty or general fund?
We sometimes recover funds. I mean, we did it,
we recovered funds for the city a significant amount when
we were sent defective masks during the pandemic.
For example, we recently settled
the Allens Creek Reservoir matter that
we took issue with state legislation we were able to prevail
and we received, even if it's not in direct dollars
over time, what I think will be substantial savings to the city.
I think you had mentioned in your presentation that the
city of Houston at one point in time was towards the bottom when it
came to is that major cities of competitive salary?
Yes, that's right. That would be San Antonio,
Dallas, Fort Worth. And also comparing locally here to Harris
County and Metro. Where are we now?
We're at the median. We're right there.
We think where we should be for the time being. And what are our efforts
for recruitment at the different law firms of the law schools
to try to attain the best talent?
Frankly, I think we need to probably take
a more direct approach to working with the local law schools, working with
the deans. I've had a couple of conversations.
We do get a lot of interest from
lawyers and we have been able to, I think,
hire some talented young lawyers from the local law schools
or who coming out of practice here. We do sometimes have a
bit difficulty trying to hire in some of the more specialty areas,
for example water rights or It technology.
Thank you. Next, we'll have questions by council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you. Vice Chair city Attorney. Michelle, first off,
just a huge thank you and moment
of gratitude to you and the entire team. I know that you break down
all the different specialties that your office takes care of,
but I don't think it's really hard to grasp
how much you all actually do day in and day
out, all of the different matters that you all have eyes on.
Remind me how many people are in your department,
roughly? I think we have about 170.
I know that's not precise, but that's okay. But again,
thank you, because I know we often see items
come up where we're seeking outside counsel, but that doesn't take away from
the extensive amount of work that you all do. And thank you for always
being so responsive to my office on things.
Really quickly, the court
backlogs and delays that we've seen that the county
is facing, how has that had an impact, if any, on city
related litigation? I think it's primarily
affected it in two ways.
One, I think our municipal courts, now that in
person hearings and trials are occurring,
you have a rush now because of the backlog, although it wasn't quite
what it was in the civil courts. What I think we
see in the civil courts in an area that we've had some concern
because we've been trying to staff, is really in the tort cases.
And so now that the courts are backlogged, we're seeing
more and more, and particularly when we need lawyers and also
paralegals, it's been difficult to find paralegals. It's difficult to compete with the
private sector, too. So I think that has just really added to the
constraints that we have as a public entity law firm during
the pandemic. I know, for example, when lots of people
are home, we got at least the district offices, a lot more
calls, right, of issues and things like that. Did your office see
a higher influx or
cases and issues remaining steady?
Yeah, I think that there were particular
challenges and different types of issues that had to be raised,
that we had to address. And I think much of that happened before I
arrived. And I think Deirdre Penny and Randy Zamora and the team did
an excellent job. Absolutely. And finally,
what are the needs, given the financial constraints that the city
continues to face, the revenue cap, et cetera? What are the needs
of the foreseeable future that we should be aware of that aren't
addressed in this in your budget this year?
I think if you had a wish list, you would probably try to expand
more in support services within the department,
paralegals the ability to
investigate claims, particularly in the neighborhood. For example, if you look at neighborhood
services, they filed eleven Chapter
125 lawsuits. They've been successful in challenging Sobs
bars Spiveys on Blodgett Street, for example.
But those take time and those take efforts in addition to what HPD
provides. Thank you. And if it would be possible,
Vice Chair, to put me back in queue, I'd appreciate it.
Sure. I also want to welcome Council Member Amy Peck,
council Member Mary NAN Huffman, and Council Member David Robinson to
the chambers. Next, we'll have questions and staff
from District K and District D council member Sally
Alcorn. Thank you, Chair.
And shout out to Randy Zamora for all the good work he did on
the noise ordinance sitting there behind you on paper reduction.
Legal is a lot of paper. And are you all doing,
DocuSigns? Are you all trying to cut down on contract papers going back and
forth? Can you describe a little bit of your efforts there?
Yeah, I think we pay money to Harris County Department of
Ed to archive, and we need to go as paperless
as possible. That can't be done in all instances depending
on what a particular court you're in and what's being required.
We have that, but I think everyone in
the department is conscious of the need to use less paper.
It affects our bottom line, and frankly, it makes it more efficient
in being able to identify and find something after
the fact. So there's not really an orchestrated effort.
It's just kind of, let's try to do better, or is there anything kind
of in place to there is specific reduction efforts.
There is not a plan.
I'm going to take that under advisement and look at it and see what other
departments are doing in order to do that. I do know that
it just makes us more efficient when we do that. And I think every lawyer,
our lawyers are frankly overwhelmed in what they have to do,
and they will always find ways to make it more efficient. But you bring up
a good point. Thank you.
That is a good point. I know that my law firm, we try to
be efficient with going paperless, but you kind of
are also very accustomed to having those
paper files in front of you and you like to grab them and write notes
and you know where they are. And sometimes going paperless
at a law firm, it sounds like it could be more efficient,
but sometimes it could be a little frustrating
as well. So I know that that balance is something that you all will continue
to consider and find a way to make it work.
Council member amy Abby Cayman. Sorry,
it was a close one.
City Attorney as it relates to
numbers and metrics, it's hard, right? Some departments can
have easy metrics. Your department,
what someone may think is a win in court is
actually a better win because we have a settlement, less court costs,
et cetera. Do you track
numbers and things like that? How much dollars are
generated from settlements, things of that nature that would be available?
Yeah, we do. Much of our
litigation is defensive, so you also would
have to look at the amount sought realistically,
what we felt a judge or jury could award,
and if we were able to settle for less things of that nature.
We do have litigation where we're the plaintiff that we can
look at that. But yeah, we do have that data. Okay, again,
just wondering. I think you all do a phenomenal job, as council
members mentioned, randy, with the sound ordinance,
the didras as I like to say on multiple things. But again,
the entire team just really appreciate all
of y'all's work. Thank you.
Well, again, we want to thank you for your presentation, City Attorney
Michelle, and to you and your entire staff for all the contributions.
We know you all do a lot with a little, and you all do a
great job of collaborating and engaging with our offices. So continue
the good work and thank you again, and you may be dismissed.
Thank you. We will now begin
the public comment period. We will start with our virtual public
speakers. Please press star six to unmute. When you hear
your name, the first speaker will be
Saba Blanding. Please press hi. Good afternoon.
Can you all hear me okay? Yes, ma'am. Okay,
wonderful. I had a few questions on slide 20.
It says that the legal department negotiated police and
municipal employee union contracts. I was wondering
if there's a plan to make this process public like in other cities,
and if not, why? I was also curious when
and how the Office of Policing Reform and Accountability is
planning to implement community led recommendations
around policing beyond the mayor's appointees. I was
also curious council Member came and addressed this in an earlier department
presentation. But what are plans to extend
the prenatal parental and infant wellness leave ordinance?
And finally, I was personally curious about
what percentage of funding, for one, Safe Houston is outside of HPD.
Particularly curious about violence interruption and prevention measures and
youth outreach. It makes sense how it's set up on the website by
an issue. But just in terms of budgeting, I'm curious
how the breakout is with departments.
Ms. Blanding, I'm going to give you some additional time because I know you were
kind of running through those questions so that we
could ensure that we got it all in the allotted time. But can you please
repeat question one and speak a little slower
for us? Yeah,
sorry. You know, I'm trying to get in, like, 23 questions.
My first question was that on slide 20, it says that the
legal department is the one that negotiates the police and municipal
Employees union contracts. And I was curious if there's a
plan to make this process public like in other cities, including in
Texas. And if not, why not? That was my
first question. So on that first question, you are right.
The city legal department does negotiate
with the Houston Police Officers Union. I think when it comes
to plans moving forward, that is something that will be discussed
between the mayor and the city attorney
each particular year on their vision and their perspective on what
may be beneficial for the city of Houston as it pertains to the negotiation
process. We are aware that other cities do have what
may be considered a more open process,
but those considerations lie solely with the mayor,
his vision, and working with the city attorney.
Did you need me to repeat my other questions. I know I was trying to
get them really quick. Yes, please. Okay.
I was getting a little winded too. So my second question
was when and how is the Office of Policing Reform
and Accountability planning to implement community led recommendations
around policing? So just beyond the appointees, some more community led input?
Yeah, I think that's a great question, and I would like to see that as
well. I would request that
the chair of the Public Safety Committee kind of look into that somewhat to
see if that's something we can get on the schedule as a way in
which we can take questions from the public to be
able to submit to that
oversight office and then be able to provide some
type of feedback. Or you can always reach out directly to
your specific district Council member on advocating
for that as well. For the District J office,
I can say that I would lean towards trying to find a way to
collaborate with Ms. O'core to do
maybe a virtual town hall where
we can submit some questions from the public and then be able to provide
those answers.
Okay. And to repeat my third question, and this is more to
Council Member Cayman, perhaps you addressed
this in an earlier department presentation, but I was curious about any
plans to extend the prenatal Parental and Infant Wellness
Leave Ordinance saba
as it relates to expansion of the paid parental
leave program. All City
of Houston employees are currently covered.
The mayor has asked and we as council members are
encouraging affiliated arms of
the city that may not be within council's direct control, for example,
Metro, Houston, first, et cetera, to begin
looking at that for their employees as
well as for contractors,
subcontractors, et cetera. I do know that other work
is being done by the Women's Commission, but I cannot speak to that.
Okay, I appreciate that clarification about the process.
And then my final question was what percentage of funding
for one Safe Houston is outside of HPD?
And I was particularly curious about the violence interruption and prevention measures
and the youth outreach. So right now on the website, it's broken down by
domestic violence, which makes sense. But as
this is budget hearings and we're looking at particular department budgets,
I was curious to see those numbers by department.
So that was my final question, and I appreciate the time to kind of repeat
in a non rushed manner. Great question. We will
get that final answer for you to make sure that
we have the specific line items and broken down for you in
an itemized fashion. So please ensure that you send that specific
question over to the District E at houstontx Gov and
then we will respond promptly.
Thank you. Our next public speaker is Mr. Jason Oliver.
Oh, perfect. Okay, good afternoon,
everyone. So, first, let's see.
Okay, so I'm curious about the municipal,
the employee contracts as well and I also
know that the municipal contracts are a lot more transparent
than, say, the police union. And we haven't had fire negotiations
in a long time. But I'm curious about how much in
raises have been authorized for each of the three major employee groups.
I know that's a little bit detailed, so I'll make sure to send
that one in second. This is going along with
Council Member Pollard. I know you brought the transparency
dashboard project comport. I'm curious about
how many complaints have been received through that dashboard and
how can we bring because it doesn't actually publish the
complaints like Project Comport does. I'm hoping that we can bring that
back into the scope of this new dashboard that's
been put together. And then finally,
neighborhood support for deed restriction has
been a big need that I've heard from community members. I'm curious about
if it's possible to expand the types of legal
support that the department can offer to communities
and, like, civic clubs that are looking for deed restriction support.
All right, great question. I believe on the employee
contracts fire, they receive
6% increase over the next three years.
Police receive 4%, and municipal employees 3%.
As it pertains to the Police Transparency Dashboard,
those numbers are consistently being reevaluated.
And as you have a question to that,
wanting to know more about how many inquiries are coming into that
portal, so do I. And so I will be reaching out to Mr.
Core for those answers as well. And I
think we need to do a better job as a city in really highlighting the
Police Transparency Dashboard. That's something that I'm proud
of, but not enough people kind of understand the functionality
of it, as well as kind of how to navigate it and use
it to their benefit. So I'm going to put that on my shoulders
to get more engagement from the public and awareness on
how to utilize that. And my
office will reach out to you directly. I'm going to make a note of that
so that we can collaborate on getting some engagement. And then
your third question was the
increased deed restriction enforcement support.
So, of course, as you heard in the presentation earlier, our legal department
is spread pretty thin as it is with all of the different practice
areas that they cover. So to add on to that with civic
clubs or HOAs when it comes to D restrictions,
I think would be challenging. So we have to be creative in our approach
in working with Lone Star Legal Aid and others to be able to bring
forth those services to the public. I know in District J, we have
several entities like the India House and Catholic
Charities who provide weekend legal services for
residents at no cost. And so we need to do a
better job in maybe getting that information out to our constituents.
And so I would request that everyone please sign up for your
district council. Members newsletters because they put a
lot of good information out there regarding those issues.
And I know with the district J. Pollard Press, we try to provide
information on free legal services each month for
our residents as well.
That concludes the public speakers list.